uh anthony davis goes for 34-5 his sixth
game of at least 30 in the postseason is
third in this
series jamal murray his scoring has gone
up in every game from 21 to 25 to 28
32 on this night his sixth game
uh of at least 30 in the postseason but
the lakers take it 114 108 and uh
this was frank vogel in the locker room
after the game
this that's a hell of a gritty win um
brian great job stepping up on murray
okay with the single coverage down the
stretch that was big time a d
way to carry scoring load okay
supporting the cast doing what you do
dwight
great job in the start okay well done
brother behind me
okay we got one one win to get to the
nba finals but we know it's gonna be the
toughest one right
let's lock in and get it on three one
two three
the state farm audio assist 114 108 the
final
the joker remember game two
the a.d game winner but it was him and
and jokic back and forth down the
stretch and yogurt scored the last 12
points of the game
for denver last two fourth quarters no
points
no assists over five from the floor in
foul trouble tonight as you guys
mentioned
i i told you ernie i said i i he played
better i thought he was gonna play in
game
three uh he got off to a great start but
i said i think this kid's gonna be tired
because he has to do so much
he was trying to wield them to win and
clearly he's getting tired in these
games i mean
he's a great player but he used all his
energy up
in game that in that fourth quarter in
game two
can you use that as an excuse honestly
yeah yeah yeah david's got to guard him
yeah that's about the truth
are you kidding me after david don't
have to do what he do
he has to get every rebound make every
pass make every shot to join him
and show no please been doing that for
seven no no no it ain't true
and so is every other great player no no
no no no no i'm not saying that he
i'm not saying that he's a joke he's not
agree he's a great player you guys know
you expect a lot of great players you
got to play both of them come out one
second
jamal murray
that's tough
i currently have no hands we'll go to
harrison wynn
harrison go ahead
hey jamal just the offensive rebound
tonight especially the big ones that
they got down the stretch and how big of
a difference did you feel like that made
it what's the difference
next we'll go to mark hizlam mark go
ahead
he's being guarded by lebron james down
the stretch the ultimate
sign of respect and what did you learn
from that
i mean they switch id onto me too i see
lebron i do the same
stuff i do when i see crew so and
same duff when i see rondo and kcp
and kawaii and pg and pap
and royce i might do the same same thing
so appreciate the respect but always
win the game
that was something to see down the
stretch shaq as as lebron took it on
himself
to uh to guard murray and try to slow
him down and that's what great players
do what great leaders do but i wouldn't
say
it's lebron stopping him they just went
cold in the last couple minutes and you
know back to joker
i don't really think he's tired of just
thinking tonight with him foul trouble
because
listen he's a great player he's really
great when he's in the rhythm when you
have to sit six seven eight minutes
and the coach is saving you and you try
to come back in the game
a lot of times your rhythm is not there
so i'm i'm not gonna you know he's tired
and all that stop it
and i'm gonna disagree i mean we can
disagree i think i think that it takes
especially when dwight i got to give
frank vogel some credit
uh he bought dwight in there and dwight
was making him work so hard the first
quarter
like like i say he and then he has to
guard a.d
there's not many great players let's be
honest
there's not many great players had to
guard to other teams
quote unquote best player when when you
talk about not being great players where
well in the nba what are you talking
about michael jordan does it kawhi
leonard does it no no no
no the best player is the best player
ever
not true not true he doesn't guard the
best players the best of those players
koala designed his position wait well he
didn't he didn't do he didn't guard
uh uh uh my boy down to dallas every
time
he did not he did not no he's god's the
best player
no that's not true that is not true uh
and uh not guarding
anthony davis every play either i know
what i'm saying he has to guard half the
dave's majority of the game
they're switching trucking every player
they are switching but i'm telling you
he knows he's
gonna guard him disagree listen
he's a great player i think we can't
give him an excuse i'm not giving him
excuses
he's still playing pretty good but he
listen i'm just saying he has a lot of
responsibility on that denver team
and every great player does that's not
true they don't have to guard a guy like
alan davis on the other end
bro if they're switching he's going to
guard him every time uh
sometimes yes most of the time you guard
a car no but he's not going to do
everything on outfit everybody does that
you go when you get to that
western conference that's not true
david robinson like the great players
that when you get to the final four
you're going to be playing against
you're not playing against godzilla
first of all i understand that
if that's rare what are the two best
centers and somebody in the in the game
they're switching no we're turning what
i'm saying he's still having to guard
anthony davis on the other end that's a
lot to ask that kid to do
not even what's the conference fine now
you want to win an nba final i give you
be a lot to ask what you're saying
during the regular season game number
10. but not
not a lot in the question he has the
ability to do it we can disagree
telling numbers in this and you heard
jamal murray
talk about it the 12 offensive rebounds
for the lakers
25 second chance points they had 32 for
the series coming in
25 tonight so they win that department
25 to 6.
and we talked about the free throw we
talked about the lakers
going to the nba about lebron james and
his free throw attempts well let me say
this tonight he has 14.
tonight the lakers hit more free throws
than denver took
28 out of 35 to 20 for 23. i'm not i'm
not going to say that
the revs cost to doug it's a game that's
not fair but that was an awful awful
officiated game really then so yeah it
was awful
because uh you just there were so many
called like lebron knocked the hell out
of murder he went to the basket that
last time even reggie and chris said it
but it was an awfully officiated game in
my opinion you got to move your feet you
can't be out there flopping it's the
final four
now man up right kenny hey man
don't need to go 108 for the car you got
the man up we'll take a little break
here
on inside the nba
rbg won't you come down here and help me
i'm not charlotte
oh my gosh yeah that's more better right
there
fine next wow oh
[Music]